[موسيقى]
السبب الاول هو التقديرات الخاطئه من قبل
الشركه المنفذه والمصممه بسبب اعتمادها
على بيانات قليله للامطار انذاك السبب
الثاني اللي هو بعث فيضانه 86 حدث تشققات
وتصدعات اهمل من ناحيه الصيانه ولم تقم
الدوله باعمال اي صيانه بعد هذا الفيضان
السبب الاخر هو عدم الاهتمام بتنظيف بحيره
السد مما ادى الى تجمع عديد من الرواسب
الطينيه
عملت لود زائد على السد السبب الاخر اللي
هو المفيض السد الموجود كان حجم صغير ولا
يستطيع ان يستوعب كميات كبيره من المياه
كذلك زياده معامل جريان السطحي مع مرور
الوقت بسبب عوامل التعريه كذلك عدم وجود
انذار مبكر
متكامل لجسم السد السبب الرئيسي وهو ان
عاصفه دانيال حملت معها كميه كبيره من
الامطار استمرت شدتها الى ساعات طويله مما
احدثت فيضان ضخم ادى الى عدم استيعاب
الموجود لكميه المياه فحدث اوف ما ادى الى
انهيار اسد كذلك هناك سبب رئيسي اخر وهو
ان الشركه المنفذه والمصممه اقترحت تصميم
ثلاثه سدود من ضمنها سد يقام في الجزء
الاوسط للتخفيف على سد بمنصور هذا المشروع
لم يتم انجازه فاصبح سد منصور عباره عن
قنبله منقوته
[موسيقى]
المدى البعيد لو ان الدوله اهتمت بصيانه
السدود وبتنميه حوض وادي دارنا بتقليل
معامل الجيرين غطاء النباتي وقامت عده
سدود تعويقيه بتخفيف سرعه اجرين السطحي
وحجم اجرين السطحي بالاضافه الى تنفيذ
مشروع السد الثالث لما حدثت هذه الكارثه
ولا استطعت سد بماسور تحمل كميات المياه
التي استقبلها على المستوى القريبه
والمرحله القريبه هي قبل عاصفه دانيال
باسبوع كانت على لجنه الطوارئ التنسيق مع
المتخصصين في مجال الهيدرولوجي
والهيدروليكا وموارد المائيه بحيث يتم
التركيز على المناطق القريبه من الحوض
ودلتا الحوض ولكن مع الاسف الشديد الاخوه
في لجنه الطوارئ ورغم من حرصهم الشديد
وبالرغم من تفانيلهم في العمل برغم من
تحذير المخاوفهم عدم المواطنين كما انها
قدموا العديد من الضحايا والشهداء ربي
تقبلهم عند برحمته
عملوا على او توقعوا ان الكارثه تحدث عن
طريق زلزال في البحر وحدوث موجات فاصبحوا
يحذرون
التجمعات السكنيه على مناطق الساحليه
واهمل منطقه
وادي درنه وجريان سطحي والفيضان ومنطقه
الدلتا بالكامل
علاقه بحوض وادي الدرنه
لدراسه الماجستير في جامعه طرابلس بدات
بتجميع البيانات والمعلومات لدراسه
المشاكل الموجوده في الحوض من خلال تجميع
لهذه البيانات اطلعت على تقارير مخيفه
حقيقه من الخفراء لدى الهيئه العامه
للمياه اذكر منها على سبيل المثال الخطير
استاذ ابراهيم القاضي والاستاذ عبد الجواد
بوبيضه يعني تحدثوا وحذروا من كارثه وشركه
من ذلك الوقت حيث ان السدود عرضت الى
تشققات بعض فيضان 1986 يعني هبوط في
الاكتاف وتسرب كميات كبيره من المياه كذلك
الشركه السويسريه التي قدمت تقريرها في
2002 يعني من خلال هذه التقارير التي
اطلعت عليها وجدت ان المشكله كبيره في حوض
وادي دارنا ماذا دفعني الى دراسه الحوض
بشكل متكامل وتقييم الجريان السطحي
[موسيقى]
طبعا توجد العديد من السدود على مستوى
الدوله الليبيه الدوله الليبيه قامت
بانشاء هذه السدود لتحقيق عده اهداف
رئيسيه منها حمايه المدن وتجمعات السكنيه
من اخطاء الفيضانات كذلك تغذيه الخزانات
الجوفيه حمايه التربه من الانجراف
سبب اخر اللي هو استغلال كميه هذه المياه
الاغراض الزراعيه طبعا نتيجه لان عمر هذه
السدود يعني فاقل اربعين سنه في معظمها
يعني اهمل جانب الصيانه فيها فبالتالي
ممكن ان تحدث كوارث المستقبل اذا استمر
هذا الاهمال وعدم الصيانه وعدم وجود نظام
انذار مبكر بالاضافه الى عدم تنميه
الاحواض المائيه الكبيره وخاصه منها حوض
وادي القطاره
هذه السدود الثلاثه توجد في هذه الاحواض
ثلاث سدود كبيره يعني ممكن ان تسبب خطر
على التجمعات السكنيه